いつも
動画を見てくださってありがとうござい
ます肇社長です
今回は
今から
かなり大きな
重大な報告をさせていただきます
是非最後までこの動画をご覧下さい
先に言っておきますが悪い報告ではあり
ません
かなり良い報告です
ちょっと待ってくださいパーなんだ丸い
報告じゃないのかと残念な顔をしないで
下さい是非最後までこの動画を見て
ください必ず必ず
間近えっ
8必ず言うと思います分かりませんがただ
かなりすごいことになってきておりますで
は
発表させていただきます
th
どうも
調査兵団の
弾いや母番です
神父様じゃーん
[音楽]
どうもあの超調査兵団よっては田治米社長
です
やばい報告してもいいでしょうか皆さん
あの有名なアニメ進撃の巨人ご存知
でしょうかもちろん大勢の人は知ってる
でしょ聞いたことを耳にしたこと絶対ある
と思います味見の進撃の巨人に見たこと
ある方どれ位いらっしゃいますか
あと見たことある人まだ聴いてください皆
ことない人は絶対見てください味見の心理
キムチずめちゃくちゃ話題になってて
ハックががめっちゃ機で音楽も最高本当に
大絶賛されているアニメ進撃の巨人がある
んですけどもその1機をですね先日私の肇
社長2サブチャンネルの方になんと
アニメをアニメ一挙そのバンガゼ馬出させ
ていただいて
あのこれヤバイことわかってます
ユーチューバーのチャンネルにアニメが丸
ごと全部出るんですよ大人の事情で期間
兄弟でして歩きかに行ったら全部非公開に
行って今を見れないんですけども
これ
結構歴史動いてると思うんですよおかげ
さまでですねはじめシャツ o 2の進撃
の巨人もうめちゃくちゃ人気ですっごい
たくさんの方に見ていただいてもうなんか
責め茶筒=進撃の巨人みたいになった時期
もあったんですけども
発表させていただきます
ほんとすごいよ今回では発表させて
いただきます
死んだぞやあん
テレビアニメ進撃の巨人チーズ右腕の動画
を全て再公開25全部再公開そして
鈴ん2巻ファイナルの part 1まで
に16はから75雨0すべてのどうぞ今回
しゅわーっ
[音楽]
wh
なんでそんなことしていいのちょっとは
ないかああ
嬉しいれるテンションあがりすぎて何言っ
てたかわかんねっていう方の為にもう1回
言わせていただきます肇社長2にて非公開
になっていたテレビアニメ進撃の巨人の
part 1市場から25は全部再公開し
ますもう1回観れますこれで審議の基準見
たことないよっていう人も市場から始め
社長2のチャンネルで全部見れますそして
もうねかねぇ無いって言われてたんで結構
テレビアニメをユーチューバーの
チャンネルに出すことってどんなことだと
思いまーねそのもありましたアニメってさ
普通なら有料で見るものだと思うんです
けどもそれを2022年の1月の9日の
日曜日の24:05 nhk 総合にて
放送開始されますテレビアニメ進撃の巨人
theファイナルシーズンの放送進撃の
巨人のファイナルシーズンを盛り上げる
ためにユーチューバーのチャンネルに進撃
の巨人のアニメが全部出るんですよ
現在ミョンでしょ普通にというわけで簡単
にいうと僕のチャンネルでディッキーが
ファイナルまで見れるということでござい
ます
本当にって本当にすごいてありがとうで
本当にすごいんで行ってこれはねぇ
ちょっと意味わかんないね進撃の巨人の
一気僕のチャンネルで見てた人ならわかる
と思うんですけどももう実機を築きという
か僕もつ形に言って僕と一緒に見るみたい
な感じでちょっとファイナルシーズンまで
一緒にぜひみましょう本当にありがとう
ございますあの多分
なんでこんなことができるようになったか
というとで半分って言われてるんですよ1
機だけならまだ分かると進撃の巨人の入り
の部分だから1機だけだったらまぁまぁ
まぁこれを見て進撃の巨人興味を持って
もらえたらいいなぐらいで一気ぐらいだっ
たら僕の3年目がおかしいですけどそれが
おかしいですけど most じゃあ出す
とわかるんですけども
日からファイナルは全部イッちゃいま
すぅぅぅぅうお金取ってよお金とっては
それはすごい爆品だよ進撃の巨人って本当
にはじめ眼科恐れ全霊で俺のチャンネルで
ザって犬がって思ったら何か
なんでこんなことできるかと言うと
やっぱり1期だった時に反響がすごくて
コメント等日記みたいな溢れかえっていた
んですよ本当に視聴者さんみんなで見てる
感覚がすごい楽しくてぜひともあの進撃の
巨人の感動来年始まる新駅で求人ザ
ファイナルシーズンに向けてみんなでお
さらいしましょう
見たことない人は僕と一緒に全部み
ましょう1箱全部一緒に見えます
平和すごいぞディバインちょという気で
通過始めるわけではなくてとりあえず1基
を全部非公開にしてたんですけども再公開
しますぜひ進撃の巨人まだ見たことないよ
という人は第一話から始めしちょっつーで
見れますので是非見てみてくださいあの僕
実況でついてるって言ってもあんまりあの
いや the となりドルめっちゃ
しゃべってたら台写真とか俺も飲んでまず
目に見えちゃってるからそんなにウザく
ないぐらいおしゃべり方してると思います
二撃の巨人2期からもファイナルシーズン
もそんな感じでボクサーも一緒に見てると
思うのでぜひ見ていきましょう一応ね一気
に貼って出すわけではなくて1日1話ずつ
出していこうかなと思ってます審議の巨人
日222223分ぐらい一番あるでけれど
も音が僕のイメージだと深夜夜中の方が
みんな仲時間あるかなと思ってもしこの
進撃の巨人のシーズン2の公開始まったら
夜の23時郊外にしようかなとなんとなく
考えておりますちょっと細かい情報はです
ね僕のツイッターとか見てくださると
詳しく説明いたしますので一夏1基が全て
再公開になったということでぜひ見たこと
ないともう見た人復讐のために見ても良い
と思います進撃の巨人入りなシーズンまで
はじめ者ちょっつーのチャンネルねー
楽しんでいってくださいアニメ進撃の巨人
の the fine らしいず一緒に
向かいましょうじゃあな
あっは
[音楽]
clar